bonjour à tous
donc jean calvin terrain j'ai 19 ans et
je suis actuellement étudiant à
montpellier
alors avant de commencer mon thèse je
voudrais commencer et faire un stage
dans les salles et j'aurais savoir quels
sont ceux à mon goût quand la question
que le temps larry schook que vous avez
pas assez dans une journée comme ça tout
ce que vous voudriez faire
que voudriez bien faire si vous faire ça
mais que vous avez devant vous invite à
lever la main si vous vous sentez
concerné par ça
[Musique]
jack a beaucoup beaucoup dans la salle
c'était la magie qui sentent concernés
par femme et moi aussi bien sûr je me
sens concernée et finalement est ce qu
on se laisserait pas dicter dans notre
vie de tous les jours nous essaierons
des calendriers qui sont fixées par
d'autres
est ce que finalement on continuerait
pas notre vie sans trop se poser de
questions parce que de toute façon tu
entraînes poser des questions et pour
vous illustrer ça je vais vous raconter
une expérience que j'ai vécue il ya deux
ans en fait quand j'avais 17 ans et que
je suis entré en prépa scientifique
en fait quand j'étais un petit peu aux
réserves des milliers en matière
d'orientation contre toute attente
d'ailleurs parce qu'on pourrait se dire
en terminale on a beaucoup
d'informations sur ça finalement on
n'avait pas des bancs et comme j'étais
un peu débile 10 par rapport à ça et que
j'avais eu des très bonnes notes vous au
long de la scolarité
en fait tout mon entourage et mes profs
de l'époque m'ont dit tu sais on avec
ses potes il faudra
tu passerais pas tu verras c'est pour
viendra et du coup c'est ce que j'ai
fait en fait j'ai écouté ses conseils et
j'ai décidé en fait après être passé par
admission postbac
s'il ya déjà dans la salle vous savez ce
que c'est c'était assez évident le
concernant les agences le post bac et
c'était vraiment un sympathique et donc
après avoir campé sur abb et et avoir
obtenu avec mention très bien j'ai
intégré cette fameuse pépin est donc en
fait je suis arrivé on prépare un petit
peu là yvon va dire comme femme athée la
banda ya % avaient un peu d'aller par
rapport aux attentes
calvet les processeurs de prépa et donc
lavées recommencer voilà surtout sur de
bonnes bases
et puis finalement elle et s'est déroulé
et je me suis rendu compte l'année avec
des passages étaient scandés que j'ai
essayé de passer mon temps à rattraper
tant il bref j'arrive à la fin d'année
et je savais plus du tout plu du tout
pourquoi j'ai fait la moue pourquoi
j'avais choisi ça qu'est ce que je
faisais là on s'en fout et donc c'était
un peu une grande remise en question et
il ya plusieurs facteurs en rimes en
année 1 et direct
principal qui m'a amené à me poser des
questions existentielles
c'est le temps parce que ce temps il a
dit il à toute vitesse et pas voilà je
me suis retrouvé à la fin d'année a plus
du tout savoir quelles étaient vos
objectifs de vie en fait qu'est ce que
je voulais pas et ce que je voudrais
essayer de vous transmettre à travers ce
tank
même si j'ai 19 ans c'est que j'ai
vraiment appris quelque chose quand
cette année très bas qui est qu' il faut
essayer de prendre du temps le trouver
essayer de se poser et de se recentrer
pour vraiment savoir ce qu'on veut
vraiment faire ce qui nous passionne
ce conte enfants nous et que des fois on
va pas pas semblé trop focus est sur
quelque chose qui finalement on va
peut-être par an alors bien sûr on
prépare j'ai aussi appris des choses qui
m'ont fait évoluer outre la méthode de
travail que j'ai toujours et que
j'applique j'ai aussi
appuyez sur le côté développement
personnel parce que maintenant j'arrive
à faire de la méditation un petit peu
tous les jours quand je suis pas le
dalaï lama mais voilà j'arrive à plus me
poser est aussi capable prendre la tête
sur un petit problème tout petit petit
mais quand on a vu les dessus ça m'a
tellement énorme et aussi j'aimerais
jamais j'ai trop de choses à faire c'est
possible et ça m'a vraiment élevé cette
année la trempe du recul sur les choses
et à mesure bon bah c'est pas grave
parce avons changé et je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui se retrouvera
peut-être 40 50 ans et qui font une
espèce de crise existentielle on va dire
parce qu'en fait ça plus trop qu'est-ce
qu'ils font pourquoi ils font ce job là
ils se retrouvent et de 10 ans si
j'avais pu voyager
enfin si j'avais pu être astronaute
au lieu d'être dans les nuages
et voilà et voilà ce que je pense à
faire passer c'est essayer de vous
asseoir de minutes
même si vous pensez que c'est une perte
de temps c'est pas une heure de temps
vraiment pas ce que vous allez savoir
vraiment ce qui vous plaît et ce qui
vous passionne et je pense que c'est
vraiment ce qu'est dior parfums
est ce que je devrais vous dire c'est
que nous si comme beaucoup de gens qui
ont tendance à révéleront fait plutôt en
sorte de vivre libre et merci
[Applaudissements]